[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es bei uns gleich ein leckeres Mittagessen
oder Abendessen – wir essen ja immer ein bisschen später.
Esst ihr eigentlich Mittagessen warm
oder seid ihr eher so der Abendessertyp?
Also bei uns ist es so, wir frühstücken doch relativ spät
und dann gibt es eher ein Abendessen. Und dazwischen nur Snacks.
Egal, anderes Thema. Heute gibt es ein leckeres Gericht.
Ich mache nämlich eine Bowl aus Hähnchen mit Reis,
einer leckeren Tomaten-Bruschetta und Parmesan-Zucchiniwürfeln.
Ich glaube, es wird ziemlich lecker. Ich werde es auch so zubereiten,
dass ihr praktisch das Ganze toll vorbereiten könnt,
sodass eben am Ende alles gleichzeitig fertig ist.
Zuerst mache jetzt einmal das Hähnchen mit dem Reis.
Dafür nehme ich 600 g Hähnchenbrust, 3 EL Olivenöl,
etwas Paprikapulver (edelsüß), 1 Knoblauchzehe, Rosmarin,
Salz und Pfeffer, 250 g Naturreis (buntgemischt) und 500 g Wasser.
Das war es im Prinzip schon.
Ich habe jetzt noch kurz den Reis unter fließendem abgewaschen Wasser.
Jetzt könnt ihr im Prinzip schon euren Topf nehmen und erhitzen.
Ich sage ja, das ist ein recht schnelles Rezept.
Da direkt das Öl mit dazu geben. Die Knoblauchzehe
– ich habe hier jetzt eine ganz große,
aber ihr könnt auch gern eine kleinere nehmen –
kurz schälen und einfach kleinschneiden.
Ich glaube, ich nehme doch nur die Hälfte. Es wird sonst zu viel.
Wenn ich das sage, dann wird das echt zu viel.
Ich schneide sie in Scheiben.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich jetzt hier die Hähnchenbrust im Ganzen
in die Pfanne geben und anbraten.
Ich gebe da direkt noch den Knoblauch dazu
[Bratgeräusche]
und auch den Rosmarin.
Jetzt einfach rundum von allen Seiten schön braun anbraten.
Während es hier jetzt noch anbrät,
stehen wir natürlich nicht faul herum,
sondern bereiten schon einmal die Zucchini vor. Ich habe hier
2 grüne Zucchinis, etwas Olivenöl, Parmesan, Salz und Pfeffer,
vielleicht noch die restliche Knoblauchzehe.
Was ich jetzt tue: Ich werde die Zucchini in Würfel schneiden,
d. h., erst einmal halbieren.
Bei großen Zucchinis würde ich auf jeden Fall innen immer hier dieses
Kerngehäuse herausnehmen – das ist nämlich einfach nur wässrig.
Eigentlich nehme ich es immer bei allem heraus.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr das Hähnchen rundherum angebraten habt,
gebt ihr das Wasser, den Reis und die Gewürze dazu.
Jetzt hier den Reis einmal schön verteilen
und mit den Gewürzen vermischen.
Dann garen jetzt die 2 Hähnchenbrüste mit dem Reis direkt einem Topf.
Da verbindet sich der Geschmack eben auch optimal.
Wenn es kocht, den Deckel schließen, Hitze herunterstellen
und dann etwas für 20 Minuten garen lassen;
ab und zu nach dem Reis gucken, kurz durchrühren, aber in der Zeit
kann ich, wie gesagt, die Zucchinistücke weitermachen.
Die Zucchini einfach längs halbieren, also je nach Größe.
Wenn sie ein bisschen dicker ist, dann gern auch vierteln.
Dann direkt auf ein mit Backfolie belegtes Backblech legen.
[Musik]
Dann kommt jetzt hier noch einmal Olivenöl darüber,
etwas Salz und Pfeffer.
Nicht zu viel Salz, denn Parmesan kommt auch noch dazu.
Der wird jetzt hier direkt darüber gegeben.
[Musik]
Wer möchte, kann jetzt noch die Knoblauchzehe dazu pressen.
[Lacht] Hatte zu viel Druck – ups!
Jetzt einfach alles schön vermischen
und im vorgeheizten Backofen schön ausbacken.
Dann habe ich Zeit, um den Tomatensalat herzustellen.
Das backt im Ofen, das Hähnchen ist auf dem Herd.
Dann haben wir es auch gleich – ein schönes leckeres Gericht.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Für den Tomatensalat nehme ich 600 g Tomaten
- da könnt ihr gern buntgemischt nehmen -,
1 Frühlingszwiebel, Balsamicoessig, Olivenöl, Balsamicocreme,
etwas Basilikum, Salz und Pfeffer.
Guckt ab und zu nach eurem Hähnchen und auch nach den Zucchiniwürfeln.
Die rühre ich ab und zu einfach ein bisschen um,
damit sich der Parmesan gut verteilt.
Ich sehe jetzt schon, sie sind gleich fertig,
aber ich stelle sie noch einmal nach,
denn sie sind mir noch nicht kross genug.
Am Ende schalte ich dann noch einmal die Grillfunktion ein,
damit sie richtig schön von oben bräunen.
Ich rühre jetzt hier einmal das Dressing an,
d. h. Balsamicoessig, Olivenöl.
Das ist auch so das Dressing, was ich immer mache, mit Balsamicocreme.
Sie ist ein bisschen süßlich.
Das mache ich immer ganz gern, wenn ich Bruschetta mache,
also wirklich kleingeschnittene Tomaten auf geröstetem Brot
– sehr lecker!
Murat liebt es, die Kinder auch übrigens. Sie essen es auch gern.
Salz und Pfeffer hinein.
[Musik]
Jetzt einfach die Zutaten schneiden.
Dann kommt alles hier in die Schüssel.
Die Tomaten werde ich jetzt fein würfeln.
Ich liebe diese Fleischtomaten. Die haben wir auch immer im Garten.
Nur da wachsen sie jetzt noch nicht, aber die sind echt schön
und vor allem sehr lecker – die sind richtig aromatisch.
In der Türkei werden sie so groß – riesig!
[Musik]
Gut. Jetzt einfach nur noch alles vermischen.
Im Prinzip bin ich dann fertig.
Das Hähnchen nehme ich jetzt gleich heraus.
Das sollte natürlich komplett durchgegart sein.
Da müsst ihr darauf achten, dass ihr kein halbrohes Hähnchen habt.
Dann kann ich es in Streifen schneiden und die Bowl schön anrichten.
Den Tomatensaft mit hinein oder nicht?
Ja, gell? Jetzt ist er drin.
Jetzt ist alles fertig. Komm ruhig schon dazu!
SARAH: Ich komme. Sieht gut aus!
SALLY: Gell? Chicken Bowl!
SARAH: Chicken Tikka Masala.
SALLY: Nicht ganz, aber ist mir auch gerade eingefallen.
Chicken Tikka Masala.
SARAH: Das ist so ein Flow-Wort.
[Sally lacht]
Es flowt es so. Chicken Tikka Masala.
SALLY: Ich würde nur sagen, die Zucchini waren sehr klein,
denn wir zwei essen gern Gemüse und Zucchinis.
Diese reichen höchstens für uns zwei,
aber wir teilen [Sarah stimmt zu]
SARAH: Ich teile mit dir.
SALLY: Okay, und ich mit dir.
Jetzt kann ich das Hähnchen herausnehmen.
SARAH: Sollen wir es gemeinsam herausnehmen?
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Oh, guck mal!
SARAH: Das sieht aber schön aus. Sehr lecker!
SALLY: Das schneide ich jetzt so.
SARAH: Jetzt schichtest du es?
SALLY: Ja, so eine richtige schöne Bowl.
SARAH: Wenn du so eine Bowl isst...
SALLY: Ich weiß, was du fragen willst.
[Flüstert] Sie will fragen, ob ich alles verrühre oder einzeln esse.
[Trommelwirbel]
SARAH: Mischst du es durch?
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Habe ich es gesagt oder habe ich es gesagt?
SARAH: Oder isst es du es so?
SALLY: Ich esse es...
Gute Frage, weil in dem Moment, als ich es angerichtet habe,
habe ich mir dieselbe Frage gestellt.
Aber ich bin eigentlich schon so:
Ich esse dann alle Komponenten miteinander, aber nicht jetzt...
also ich würde jetzt nicht alles durchmischen. Ich kann das nicht.
SARAH: Ja, aber es gibt Menschen, die rühren dann komplett.
SALLY: Ela immer ihr Porridge. Porridge ist auch so ein Beispiel.
Da hat man auch so verschiedene Komponenten.
Ich esse eigentlich immer einzeln herunter.
SARAH: Aber ich habe dich letzten umrühren gesehen.
Nein, wer war das? Nazan!
SALLY: Ich war das nicht.
SARAH: Nazan rührt um. Komplett.
SALLY: Das zerstört voll die Optik und dann so... [Sarah stimmt zu]
SARAH: Nein, das kann ich auch nicht.
SALLY: Nein, ich muss es auch einzeln.
SARAH: Aber ich nehme auch so den Löffel
und dann eine Himbeere, ein Nüsschen [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Und Yammlou.
SARAH: Und bisschen Lamm... Lamm...
SALLY: Lammlou.
SARAH: Yammlou darauf.
Aber bei mir ist das Yammlou nach den ersten 3 Löffeln weg.
SALLY: Echt? Bei mir... Ich hebe es mir auf. Kurze Frage...
SARAH: Ist das nicht ein bisschen zu viel Reis?
SALLY: Ja! Kurze Frage zum Anrichten: Brauchst du zwei Bowls oder eine?
SARAH: Sonst ist es so einsam.
SALLY: Ja, oder? Das ist sowieso jetzt zu groß.
Das ist zu voll geworden für das Bild.
SARAH: Sollen wir es unterbauen?
SALLY: Ja, das können wir machen.
Sollen wir eine Minischüssel für uns zum Probieren machen?
SARAH: Ja.
SALLY: Ich habe da einmal etwas vorbereitet.
SARAH: Isst man das jetzt mit einer Gabel oder mit einem Löffel?
SALLY: Bist du eher der Gabel- oder Löffelesser? Ich weiß was...
Löffel! [Sarah stimmt zu] Ja, ich auch. Ich löffle es.
SARAH: Wen wundert’s.
SALLY: [Lacht] So richtig Hanni und Nanni.
Komm, ich schneide es uns aber noch kurz klein.
SARAH: Dass wir alles löffeln können.
SALLY: Dass wir probieren können.
SARAH: Weißt du, was ich auch liebe?
So Balsamico... Ist da Balsamico drin? [Sally bejaht] Mit Reis!
SALLY: Lecker!
SARAH: Das nutze ich als Sauce.
SALLY: Probiere mal!
SARAH: Ich probiere mal!
SALLY: Und ich richte noch solange an.
Ich habe hier noch eine Zitrone und eine Limette.
Die kann man auch noch...
SARAH: Dekorieren oder willst es hinein...?
SALLY: Nein, kann man dazu dekorieren und wenn man will, noch einen
Spritzer darüber geben.
SARAH: Okay, ich probiere so.
SALLY: Probiere mal, wie es dir mundet!
Ich mag es so. Also eigentlich essen wir fast jeden Tag eine Bowl.
Weil wir immer Essens...
[Beide lachen]
Weil wir auch immer Essensreste vom Vortag haben.
Dann mischen wir uns immer alles so zu einer Bowl zusammen.
SARAH: Weißt du, woran mich das gerade erinnert?
SALLY: Woran?
SARAH: An meine Oma! [Beide lachen] Sie hat das Dressing genauso gemacht.
SALLY: Echt? [Sarah bejaht] Das ist ein Kompliment!
SARAH: Ja. Da habe ich das immer mit Nudeln gegessen, das Dressing
vom Tomatensalat.
SALLY: Lecker!
SARAH: Genauso schmeckt das.
SALLY: Oder einfach Brot hinein.
SARAH: Ich grüße meine Oma.
SALLY: Ich grüße sie auch. Wie heißt sie?
SARAH: Erika.
SALLY: Oma Erika, ich grüße dich auch ganz lieb.
Dem Enkele gefällt, was ich gemacht habe.
SARAH: Ja, schmeckt wie bei dir – Tomatensalat.
SALLY: Oh, ich liebe Tomatensalat. Diese knusprigen Stücke von der
Zucchini - diese Parmesanstücke...
SARAH: Schmeckt gesund! Ich liebe so etwas! [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Sag das nicht. Die meisten sagen jetzt sowas:
Gesundes kann nicht schmecken.
SARAH: Das stimmt nicht. Man muss nur seinen Geschmack daran gewöhnen.
Wenn man zu viele Süßigkeiten isst, dann schmeckt es einem auch nicht.
SALLY: Hat sie gerade gesagt,
sie muss den Geschmack an mein Essen gewöhnen?
SARAH: So habe ich es nicht gemeint.
SALLY: Wir werden auch so immer gefragt, was wir den Tag über essen.
Ich muss sagen, wir ernähren uns schon sehr gesund.
Morgens um 10/11 Uhr gibt es ein Porridge, immer ohne Zucker, eben
nur Fruchtzucker, z. B. aus einem Apfel oder einer Banane.
Dann gibt es bei uns um 15/16 Uhr,
manchmal auch 17 oder 18 Uhr unser Mittag- bzw. Abendessen,
denn dann essen wir das, was eben gekocht wird.
Wir sind schon so, wir haben immer Salat, immer frisches Gemüse.
SARAH: Muss auch!
SALLY: Muss man auch.
Also man muss wirklich den Tag über viel Obst und Gemüse essen.
So zwischendrin, wenn wir dann Hunger haben, essen wir Karotten...
SARAH: Havuç (Karotten).
SALLY: Havuç oder Sellerie. Also schon immer viel Gemüse.
SARAH: Oder du machst uns ein Shake. Rote Beete!
SALLY: Ja, Milchshake.
SARAH: Milchshake?
SALLY: Warum ist mir Milchshake eingefallen?
Rote Beete Smoothie oder Karotte-Sellerie.
Man muss auch sagen, es ist lecker und es macht fit,
denn wenn ihr mittags – machen wir natürlich auch ab und zu einmal,
dass wir zum Dönerladen laufen
und uns da eine Döner-Box gönnen bei schönem Wetter.
SARAH: Wenn das Wetter schön ist.
SALLY: Aber danach ist man extrem müde und richtig satt.
So habt ihr einfach viele, viele gesunde Vitamine und Nährstoffe
und es schmeckt trotzdem sehr lecker.
Das war jetzt wie so eine Lehrerstunde. [Sarah stimmt zu]
Frau Özcan erklärt.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachkochen und schreibt mir gerne einmal,
Ob ihr weitere solche Rezepte sehen wollt,
wo man eben einfach ein komplettes Menü hat,
was eben auch sehr gesund und nahrhaft ist und gut aussieht.
Schreibt es gern. Es war ja jetzt auch echt schnell.
Also fast ein One-Pot sozusagen. Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Das Rezept findet ihr in meiner App, könnt die App kostenlos herunterladen.
SARAH: Oder auf dem Blog.
SALLY: Genau. Das Rezept hoch- und runterrechnen auf die bestimmten
Personenangaben usw. usf., Einkaufszettel, einmal alles...
SARAH: Glocke an.
SALLY: Glocke an, kommentieren, abonnieren...
Ela macht das doch immer.
SARAH: Ja. Sie kann das schon...
SALLY: Sie kann aus dem Schlaf.
So, ich richte es noch kurz an für die Bilder und dann essen wir.
Tschüss!
SARAH: Ich mache die Sauce darüber.
SALLY: Die ist gut, gell? Deswegen habe ich mehr Dressing gemacht,
dass man das so schälchenweise...
[Musik]